comment vas-tu ce matin très bien les
cours de self défense féminine ont
malheureusement le vent en poupe
de plus en plus fréquente est synonyme
d'une augmentation des violences faites
aux femmes
ici on vient chercher un moyen d'arriver
à se défendre face à des situations
imprévues les licenciés de cet
instructeur ont doublé depuis les cinq
dernières années
l'humain doit pas avoir de la violence
face à un autre humain c'est
complètement normal donc les femmes qui
font cette démarche ont pris conscience
quand même de leur état et veulent
reprendre leur liberté de femmes veulent
retrouver cette sensation de personnes
qui n'a pas à subir ces violences les
élèves sont conquises
aucun doute sur l'utilité de ce stage
oui c'est quelque chose qui peut être
utile et voilà qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'être costaud et musclé pour pouvoir se
défendre de se dégager en situation
difficile qu'elle sèche au moins déjà
quels sont leurs droits
et puis physiquement ça peut aider quand
même cp dit ce que les n ont qu une
scrupule aucun droit de violences
physiques de la part des hommes
ce gendarme rappelle également que les
femmes ont le droit de dire non vous
avez encore des femmes aujourd'hui qui
pensent que l on devoir de coucher avec
leur mari
même si elles sont pas d'accord alors
que non c'est un viol elles ont le droit
de dire non même si elles sont mariées
même si c'est leur mari donc je pense
que oui c'est utile d'informer les gens
en 2007 94 mille femmes ont été victimes
de viol ou de tentative de viol dans
plus de 90% des cas la victime
connaissait son agresseur
la même année 130 femmes ont été tuées
par leurs partenaires